AND HE SCORES!
NATHAN MacKINNON! ALMOST LOOKS H
IN FRONT OF
DARCY HARDER SHOO AGAIN.
RANTANEN.
BACK TO THE CAPTAIN.
IN FRONT AND
NOW MacKINNON, OPPORTUNITIES. IM
UP AND AUBE-KUBEL.
SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> DEVON T
>> WHEN YOU ARE WATCHING THIS,
THE WHOLE THING CYCLES IN AND
HE
SCORES.
THAT PUCK ROLLED THROUGH TO THE
FAROW DIFFICULT IT'S
GOING TO BE. ROADS.
SAVE, PALMIERI.ITH THE PLAY.
AFTEROUT A LITTLE BIT.
THAT'S HIS FOR THIS ISLANDER CL.
AND FOUGHT AND THAT BROUGHT THE
PENALTY.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT THE AVS REDIR.
IT LOOKED LIKE A DEAD PLAY AND
EDMONTON.
COULDN'T KEEP THAT ONE
>> DOBSON.
AHO INTO THE ANGLE, IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S IN. CLOSE.
IT SCOOTS GO SILENT.
BUT WHEN HE GETSON.
AVS COME UP WITH THE PUCK.
SENDS IT FAR SIDE INTO THE FAR
ICE AND HE SCORES!
THE CON NOW THEY
HAVE COME FROM BEHIND.